in this episode of street talk unplugged
on the other hand i'm always careful now
like as a reason specifically with
phrasing everything as a search
because a search kind of entails you
have a goal
i'm not sure if that's true in every
circumstance nowadays
scientists leverages control
to gain knowledge
they set up controlled experiments to
gain new knowledge
an engineer does the inverse they
leverage knowledge to gain control over
the future
and the same with this duality of the
exploration versus exploitation
trade-off
today we have alexander matic who is
officially the smartest guy on yannick's
discord i hope you enjoy the
conversation today if you like content
like this please consider hitting the
subscribe button and also rate our
podcast on apple podcasts anyway enjoy
the show so i'm currently a math student
at fau so friedrich alexander university
in germany
from a theoretical point of view i'm
very interested in
kind of the idea of having
known parts so fixed elements inside
neural networks
be that things that are just known to
work
so like things like known operator
training which we do at fau
but also things like having
known optimizers so
so something like having a simplex
algorithm in the middle of a neural
network which can find like certain
solutions because we know how it handles
on the extreme end of course there are
then things like logic where you can say
that
if you have for example you have a
neural network and you have a symbolic
layer on top of it
which you can very easily handle you can
very easily like explain what it's doing
so basically you have these two stages
uh maybe or maybe multiple ones which
are intermixed we have the statistical
methods which do like lots of the heavy
lifting where you don't actually know
what the task is so it's very hard to
define what a dog is even if you like
intuitively know it
but on the other hand
once you have done that partisan part so
once you have decided well this is a dog
then you can start doing like symbolic
reasoning
this layer is very much under research
at the moment
okay so something interesting about
everything you just said is
none of those are topics that we've
reached out to you for for uh discussion
and kind of what say you know help on in
the past so uh
i should actually stress we we thanked
alex um very much for his help on the
previous episode with lacoon and and
ballistririo
and that was all about i mean in
particular ballistrial's spline theory
of neural networks and
i must always stress that we're talking
about mlps clearly some of the other
more modern flavors of of neural
networks presumably do extrapolate in a
way that mlp's doesn't but alex i mean
would you mind just giving us a little
bit of a flavor on that conversation i
think it's a very interesting idea of
how you you can model the internals of a
neural network because we know that
neural networks have to extrapolate in
some shape or form we know that for
example in the validation set we know it
works fine
but we also have to have a model which
explains why if we go sometimes even
very small amounts outside of the
training data that it suddenly stops
working
i think the idea of having basically
planes or regions where the model
basically kind of does the same thing
is
it's kind of a very good explanation for
that that you basically just cut the
space rather than having
the actual smooth interpolation
right it's an intuition that maybe is a
bit subtle or difficult sometimes for
even people that are very well versed to
understand why you know we even think
that that's a
a cool intuition because we've had
multiple people come back and say things
like well yeah but if i wasn't using
relu i was i was using a smooth font and
just completely trashes all your all
your argument right and
like no it doesn't like that that was
the perspective i was coming from before
is that hey if the activation function
has a smooth area in my mind i was
imagining that a neural network was
really making use of that smooth
part that it was you know stretching it
and putting like the majority of the
data sitting on that curve because of
course like smooth curvature is going to
be so important but the lesson of the
spline theory the lesson of the
dominance of relu and everything is no
like that that little curve part is
almost irrelevant like all that really
matters is it's a toggle that turns off
and on these linear you know cells
i think people really underestimate the
like
that the reason for neural networks
working on the scale that they do is
really because they're very general
models they model things in a very
simple language basically like these
fine like splines and this is why they
generalize
if you then start doing like very
specific things like uh polynomial
regression for example is also something
you could technically do
but then you get like very much uh like
very difficult dynamics to handle it
becomes right it becomes basically
impossible to kind of
go into the future like without having
any knowledge about how the polynomial
is going to look like one of the big
ideas in neural networks is that they
learn increasingly abstract
representations
and just talking about mlps for a second
what i took from randall's work is that
that's not the case the neural networks
are just slicing and dicing the ambient
space
and
in a sense that's not learning
increasing abstractions i think a lot of
people when they think about neural
networks they think about the openai
microscope and that quite clearly shows
that if you solve an optimization
problem to find an input image that max
maximally activates a logic or a layer
or a neuron you know it looks like it's
some of the neurons might be learning an
entire face for example but forgetting
about that for a minute do you think
mlps in this view are learning those
levels of abstraction
the problem is that in a neural network
you can't really talk about objectness
as a thing
so
if you
if you want to basically approximate
this idea of having objects and higher
levels of abstraction which are also
basically higher groupings of objects
then this might be just the same as
saying like we have specific features
specific like attributes in the ambient
space and we chop it up into specific
regions so for example if i have like my
headphone case here
if i just say like
this is the same as saying i chop up the
space until i i have this as an object
at the end which is just basically just
an activation part of the network then
well i mean okay so maybe
maybe that's true i mean i don't know we
don't know but on the other hand
uh we do have we do have the human brain
as kind of an extant example the neural
network that does these certain types of
behaviors that we're interested in
replicating
and if we look at the adversarial kind
of world
um the ways in which neural networks are
deceived
seems you know radically different than
the way in which human beings are
deceived by say a magician or something
so i mean if you put a little rainbow
pixel on a bus
on a school bus i'm not gonna all of a
sudden decide that it's a jackhammer
right so
wouldn't that kind of observation i
don't know doesn't it at least provide
some intuition that maybe it's not the
same is that that abstraction isn't the
same as just chopping up the space in
increasingly finer detail
i mean again that depends on
what exactly do you mean with
abstraction in that case
because humans have a very concrete
notion of abstraction they have objects
and groups of objects and groups of
groups of objects that kind of goes up
so i could for example say this is a
caro this is a bmw it's
and you know it's kind of the same thing
it's the same
uh general idea
in a neural network you can you don't
really have these distinct objects at
least not generally
so what could happen is that that
rainbow pixel is actually like the
discriminator between being object a or
b and object b
so the level of abstraction may increase
just not in the way you would expect it
to be
i really i don't know whether you agree
with this alex but i love um
synonymizing abstraction and
extrapolation and they mean slightly
different things in different contexts
so if we start with neural networks
we're in the euclidean domain
and the way that the approximation
because if you think about it all we're
trying to do is say here's the training
data and we want to generalize around
the training data and we could do it
with an epsilon we could do it the way
decision trees do it neural networks it
turns out they use this beautiful
technique of being able to turn on all
of these different hyperplanes which are
represented by all of the neurons in the
neural network and there are
combinatorially many of them an input
example comes in
the hyperplanes get turned on if they're
on the right side of the relu boundary
and it creates all of these little
honeycomb structures and those honeycomb
structures are how we generalize outside
of the training range but i want to take
it a step further so when we talk about
extrapolation
what that really should mean is being
able to use a pattern in different parts
of the input space just like a cnn does
so a cnn would recognize a tennis ball
in any part of the input space and
that's because the prior does this
translational weight sharing
so it kind of shines the the pattern
over the input space and then we have
system two extrapolation which i would
say happens it's the same thing but
happens in in more of a logical domain
where i can use some information that
i've learned and i can extrapolate
broadly into many new situations and
experience space so that doesn't seem
very geometric anymore does it
no
but
what exactly do you mean when you say
you talk about like certain objects in
that space
what does it actually mean that you do
logical inference about something for
example
because i can tie like a logical
inference procedure to pretty much
anything arbitrary that may not mean
that the
the actual reasoning may be sound in the
real world but that's also not nothing
that's guaranteed maybe the difference
between like a human and like under a
network it's just the way
a human guarantees that certain things
correspond to real worlds basically that
the human guarantees certain semantics
and because they guarantee certain
semantics they can start reusing parts
just because he knows like if x then y
then you can reason that if you actually
see x then you can give me the y
and these are the general rules you can
apply anywhere
however even if a neural network might
learn that there's no reason that this x
implies y relation is actually something
that has any correspondence to the real
world that's really interesting i think
semantics are really important for
extrapolation and one thing i'd like to
explore in a minute is that in in neural
network because if we think of semantics
as being the mapping between things and
in neural networks um there are still
semantics because there are still
mappings the neural network is a bunch
of mappings but all of the mappings are
on the same level they all just mean
a kind of similarity in the most basic
sense so there's it's very difficult to
reason over that because they're all on
the same playing field but just before
we get there i think
one of the mental blocks i have is
in light of the spline theory i think of
neural networks as being hashed with
locality sensitive hashing tables and
the kind of logical inferences that
you're talking about requires a function
or it requires um some kind of
computation so
extracting um a particular polytope from
the ambient space and then summing up
all of the distances from the faces of
that
polyhedron that seems to me completely
different to executing a function yeah
it is
so
i think that that is one of the major
differences between something like a
symbolic regression and like uh like
neural networks
that the way they handle things like
neural networks are inherently
continuous just because of the way they
model things and continuous uh
continuous things don't really handle
well when you
when you take them somewhere different
just because there's so many degrees of
freedom in a continuous space
that there's
very little to actually work with in in
like generalizable rules this is why we
always use linear layers because linear
layers are something that is pretty easy
to say well uh if something is true in
some range and if you just permute it a
little bit it's probably still going to
be true discrete things discrete objects
don't really have that property
because well there is no notion of
permuting a discrete object by a small
little bit because
once you are in that abstraction range
where you have discrete things
like promoting by a small bit doesn't
really it doesn't have any meaning
anymore you can either promote it by
just completely changing it
in which case well then the inference
procedure obviously also changes
or you can do nothing because
you can't just go by an epsilon to every
uh into the entire range
so they're this distinction you know
that we're making between continuous
structures versus discrete structures
it also comes up in the exact same
context of
talking about the difference between
iterative compute
in a complexity sense versus
just a you know
a circuit whether it's forward pass you
know just some finite kind of circuit
that does a thing and what frequently
the frequent response is well yeah but
we have the universal approximation
theorem you know well if we have an
infinite neural network it's turning
complete you know all these kinds of
things i think that completely misses
sort of the point that in any practical
scenario in any practical number of
of neurons in any practical number of
time steps
these different computations
are capable of doing very different
things
so i wonder if you know how would you
how would you respond to
a connectionist for example who comes
around and and trots out you know
universal function approximation theorem
or something
for for evidence that there's no
difference between discrete you know
discrete uh computation and continuous
i think that's a big
disservice to think about what could
happen in the limit
because in the limit for example a limit
of infinite time everything is decidable
in fact it's a big difference about
what's happening in even a very very
large finite case with what happens in
an infinite case
for example there was a recent paper
called
why would i trust your bellman which
basically looks at these spell materials
and reinforcement learning
and what they do is they basically see
that kind of you can you can
decrease the batman error while still
having like an equal like equally good
um policy because basically we can shove
everything into the infinite i believe
that even if something that's in like in
the absolute limit like in the absolute
infinite cases actually equal
that
that that is really
um
that that's
that's really not not a useful statement
that's there's also a different issue
with universal approximation theorem
because
in most cases what you try to do is you
have a function
you try to basically approximate that
function that's why it's called that way
but in practice you don't actually have
a function in machine learning you have
samples from a function
and a good point and that changes things
entirely because suddenly you only have
like finite support and even if i blow
it up to infinity
like if if there's a space between two
samples which would in the ideal case
want to sample
you can't because you don't have any
samples there
so
um this is another like where infinity
is kind of hidden
because you have this infinite amount of
values it could potentially sample
even though in any practical scenario
there's only a very very finite amount
so before we um before we leave behind
you know discrete versus continuous this
almost perennial theme
on machine learning street talk i just
want to ask you to wax
philosophical for a moment about the
universe because
you know it's an open question as to
if you go fine fine enough you know down
to the planck scale or below who knows
you know is the universe
a some type of a discretized
you know computational mesh you know
whether it's a hypergraph or a grid or
some
asymmetric lattice who knows or
is it at the deepest deepest imaginable
layer or still continue to be you know
continuous
forever
uh what would you what would you guess
well if we use my minimal knowledge of
physics there's always kind of duality
between having like continuous things
like wave forms and having like discrete
objects
so i believe if you if you actually go
down to the absolute lowest level it
probably doesn't matter
what does matter however is that
in practice what you would want is you
would want to have
some decision has to be made because at
some point you're going to have to
decide do i push the button do i like uh
do i escape out because i see some other
car coming in front of me
or do i not and starting there you are
going to have discrete decisions because
you're going to have to push the button
or not push the button well not
necessarily because there's decisions
like
should i apply 1.2 newtons to the gas
pedal or
1.203 newtons to the gas pedal so there
are there are problems that that are
still you know continuous in nature
i mean we we need to still give out
continuous answers right
yes but there's always like the fun
number fundamental question of do i even
give an answer
like do it change what i'm doing for
example
so okay so you're saying you can't
escape the discrete
decision like you can't escape some
discrete
decision even if you have
uh even if you have coexisting
continuous you know quantities yeah like
at some point there are things that just
irreversible there are things where
basically you go over a hill and you
can't go back
and once you have that you have a
discreet thing
alex i know that you're really
interested in search
and i think we can tie a few threads
together nicely here um we're speaking
with stanley later today
and he has this concept of
interestingness and actually i love this
conception of um just thinking about our
lives as being a kind of search problem
i'm really interested in this notion
that greatness could just be a door in a
maze and it's within walking distance
and we could just go and open that door
and find it
but unfortunately there's
combinatorially many doors
and we need a kind of serendipity or
subjectiveness to find it stanley calls
it interestingness clearly a completely
random search would be a dumb thing to
do
i have two minds actually about this
so
one so the first hand i very much like
the idea of having very good heuristics
for example for things like in my case
for example theorem proving where it's
the case that there are billions of
different things to try
but you want to kind of narrow it down
to the interesting parts
and then you want to have these clever
algorithms which for example they learn
from failures they know because this and
that didn't work i can infer that about
the solution
so you want to have these interesting
things but also you don't want to waste
your time searching into a completely
wrong direction on the other hand i'm
always careful now like as of reason
specifically with phrasing everything as
a search
because a search kind of entails you
have a goal
i'm not sure if that's true in every
circumstance nowadays
or at least in machine learning
because what would be the goal of having
like a perfect classifier for cats
versus dogs for example
well you could just say well it's it's
perfect on the training set but that's
what you want because then it's overfit
you want to say it's perfectly
validation set but that's also not
enough what you want to do what you want
to say is given infinite data i want to
be perfect
so kind of it's
and you just implicitly define that by
saying well i can't give you the
infinity i can give you a small chunk of
it
and the problem now is
like the problem is basically
underspecified
like the search goal there many many
different goals and even if there is
a door you find it may not be the unique
door you find there may be hundreds of
thousands of doors which from your point
of view of the implicit definition are
all equally good i must admit it sounds
counter-intuitive because um kenneth
stanley says that the best way to find
what you're looking for is to not look
for it
and
the stepping stones in those mazes they
could be
goals they could be objectives and
he says that the the best way to have a
system like this is to have no objective
at all or to have an infinitude of
objectives so in some sense you're
finding stepping stones so you're
discovering objectives that you don't
know about and then it gets very murky
so it's almost like he's saying whatever
you think you want
actually if you explore down that part
of the corridor in the maze you'll
discover something even better and then
you'll start optimizing on that i've
posed a question to someone yesterday
you know imagine you wanted to be a
billionaire how would you come up with
metrics to optimize that monotonically
and it's a very difficult question the
only metric that you can come up with
it's similar to the concept of
densification and reinforcement learning
you you can design metrics in such a way
that they seem to be a little bit more
um impervious to deception so for
example you could use the concept of
diversity as a metric or stanley uses
the concept of information accumulation
or behavioral entropy as a metric so
these are things that seem like you can
monotonically optimize them and they're
still interesting enough
so as to not be a completely random
search
there's a field called inductive logic
programming which is basically the idea
that you induce a logic program by
maybe just doing like a random search up
usually something very clever basically
slice up the like hypothesis space
and the important part part about this
is that you don't actually want to have
a solution because a solution is just
going to be basically one predicate for
every piece of the training examples
which just says this is
for example you have a thousand cats and
it's just a predicate says
cat number one is a cat number two is a
cat and so on
what you want to do is you want to have
um the most general solution
so and then you already start running
into problems so the first problem is
how would you define whether or not two
things are more general than another
and
if you try to do that you very quickly
get to the idea well i actually have to
prove that you can derive the
more specific one from the more general
one and people very quickly notice that
this is impossible because it's it you
get it into decision problems instantly
so
um
but then nowadays do is they do
something called subsumption where
basically they just it approximate this
idea
but let's say you actually have an
oracle which can actually perfectly
tell you which one
is more general so it actually can solve
this decision problem for you
then you still have the problem that two
things can be more general in two very
different ways so let's say you have you
want to sort a list
is merge sword more general than a heap
sword
i don't know that there's no notion of
being able like there is no unique order
which like i said there's no unique
total order which
which gives everything
um
which sorts everything
and this is the same problem in many
search problems
because suddenly you have to
even if you do completely like random
search between random objectives you
still have to figure out did i actually
achieve what i wanted like hey did i
find what i want or is maybe that other
part is still more close to the
objective
so i think um my take on this and you
guys are going to have to bear with me
for a little bit because it's going to
get slightly philosophical but
i think there are these these dualities
um
between a parallel set of concepts and
those concepts are
past and future
knowledge and control
exploration and exploitation and i've
been thinking about this for for decades
ever since i saw this this beautiful
quote by
claude shannon you know the information
information theory guy right he said
we may have knowledge of the past
but we cannot control it
we may control the future but we have no
knowledge of it
and what that made me realize as well is
that the same duality exists between
science and engineering
so if you think about what does a
scientist do
a scientist leverages control
to gain knowledge
they set up controlled experiments to
gain new knowledge
an engineer does the inverse they
leverage knowledge
to gain control over the future
and the same with this duality of the
exploration versus exploitation
trade-off
so i think part of the reason why a lot
of the times we're talking past each
other or going around in these circles
is we've got these two different really
dual you know domains
and you're you have to kind of operate
them both at the same time and so
stanley has a great point about look if
we're just dumping all our resources
really into
engineering problems
getting better control over the future
building a rocket that goes slightly
faster or you know uses a little less
fuel or even if we're doing similar
types of things in science where we're
just refining the knowledge base that we
already have right and just making it
more and more precise we're not doing
the exploration
phase of things
and so we're never likely to really
greatly expand
that sphere of knowledge
so i think you know this is this is the
problem is that we have this duality we
have these cross purposes
and there really is this weird asymmetry
i mean it's starkly apparent with time
you know it's this really bizarre thing
like time is this bizarre concept that
befuddles
you know anybody who tries to think
about it because
we have this very sharp cut off i can't
change anything about the past
and i can't know anything about the
future
you know
maybe we're just trying to meld two dual
spaces that need to remain complimentary
you know forever
you have to manage what you know but
also like try to expand what you like
what you don't do
however i don't think they are quite
like that
that they are quite like mutually
exclusive
that you that you can do one and but
then you have to like not do the other
many of the like big engineering
advancements
sooner or later are going to lead to
like theoretical advances and the other
way around the theoretical advances lead
to like big engineering advances
i don't deny that there's a connection
there for sure i think they're they're
like this dynamo they keep
rotating and you know feeding back to
one another but i think they're very
different tasks i mean if we just if we
think about the most distilled context
of this say the multi-armed bandit
right i mean there you're at the
situation that you gave earlier where
you have a discreet choice
which arm am i to pull
you know i can pull one
that will teach me something new and
maybe give give me a reward or i can
pour one that i'm just sure will give me
give me a reward but this this dichotomy
there exists i mean there is you know an
arm may be giving you both like an arm
may be giving you both knowledge and
reward but you're analyzing them as
really separate you know spheres like i
have my uncertainty quantity and i have
my reward uh quantity so even though
they they are connected and they they
feed back to one another they do require
almost this separate sphere of analysis
even if it's linked
i i'm reminded of i think it was the
book of feynman so feynman's book where
he talked about kind of
the idea that scientists generally
speaking have a multitude of solutions
and no problems to solve and engineers
generally speaking have a multitude of
problems and no solutions to them
i went right right and what she
basically like advised people in that
book is to say
just hey like if you're a scientist you
know you're going to have like solutions
anyways but what what it advices is have
a couple of problems like maybe five or
six or maybe as much as 10 just have
them in the back of your mind and every
time you find a new solution that
may be like completely devoid of any
meaning in and of itself just take that
solution and try to plug it into one of
your problems or basically all of your
problems and try to figure out like can
i get like a new step
and that's
that's interesting it's it's stuck with
me
well you know it could be worse you
could be a mathematician who has
both tons of problems and solutions that
have no connection to uh
the real world for now and you're
waiting for for the day in which
somebody finds a connection that uh
is useful all right you're quite
uh broad you have a broad knowledge base
right and
and i'm wondering so number one is
maybe the work you're doing is so
difficult and ambiguous and the problems
you're trying to solve are so general
that it requires like a very large
you know knowledge base or it's just
that you're very broadly interested and
and you know you may be a
a jack of all trades if you will i'm
just kind of curious about how you got
to where you are now
with that breadth of breadth of
knowledge
mostly interest
so
um
i never was really that interested in
going like
like optimizing the last like couple of
percent like i know i have some friends
which like you can have a program and
they can optimize it to the result like
they sit at the same problem and just do
that and do that very very like to to an
awesome level like i don't know at
discord for example if lucas which does
that these large language models and
basically then knows like the specifics
of like how tpus internally work and the
communications between them
i could not motivate myself to like
actually learn that
but what i can do is
i can look at certain
difficult problems
and learn about those
that
it
isn't about actually achieving like a
specific goal but it's more about
getting context to whatever i'm doing
and i think that's that's a good way of
learning things to
to have that
um
to to be not be as goal oriented but
rather be
um as oriented to get much more context
to the things you already know and if
you have that context then you can get
context that context
and that that be there so you're doing
uh yeah spoken like standard you're
doing a search for yeah you're doing a
search for interestingness right like
the goal is to uh expand the context
that's interesting yeah but
but i've been
a bit more and more like uh getting to
grips with that i cannot do like i
cannot do everything like there's some
things i cannot research like into any
depth
but
i think it's it's important to have
broad knowledge about lots of different
things
just because
you don't know what's going to be useful
like i'm talking from a research point
over here but you don't know what's
going to be useful if you knew it and it
wouldn't be research anymore
i'm interested in um knowledge transfer
efficiency i'm building a code review
platform at work by the way
and uh you know one cynical view is that
the transfer of knowledge or even
acquiring knowledge is a bit like the
curse of dimensionality a kind of you
know
like information sharing between teams
goes up uh with some factorial relation
in respect to the number of people in
teams and and maybe even acquiring new
knowledge it just it just blows up
exponentially but um i've i've had a
slightly opposite reaction in some sense
so the more concepts i know those
concepts seem to extrapolate into many
other domains like anyone who learns
about probability theory for example
will start to see the world in
statistical distributions and there's
it's almost like tetris where you know
you have a few things come together and
then the whole um problem space just
kind of collapses down several layers so
that's a good analogy yeah do you have a
similar experience because i'm very
impressed with how you operate and
clearly you're extrapolating a lot of
knowledge from many other domains
definitely i think that knowledge
composes very well it's the idea of
that that most things aren't actually
that different like most things that are
studied by humans are
is kind of the same it's different views
on very very similar uh problems i did
like a couple of uh semesters ago i did
a lecture in
artificial intelligence what it was
called where like one of the big ideas
was always
um you can either optimize a problem
directly or you can say well let's just
relax that problem and just remove of
the constraints optimize that super easy
problem and then
basically go back and just one by one at
the constraints
this semester i took a course called
linear combinatorical optimization
which is what about linear combinatorial
optimization and there also the same
idea persists we have the primal problem
which basically is you have like an
initial step and for example the simplex
algorithm and you move up and find a
better solution
or you have the idea of you can start
from the outside from like a dual
problem and move back in
and basically that's adding constraints
like one after another
and
i think that for example this is one of
those ideas for two completely different
things like the one was like
uh automated planning and
uh theorem proving and the other one was
uh like optimizing across like some
geometrical object basically and it's
still it's it's basically the same idea
and i think that's true for most things
like if you if you look up certain uh
like certain topics like it's always
going to bleed over in something else
like topology has some applications
category theory and the other way around
there's tons of things
i think what you're describing is there
are abstract analogies
right which allow you to extrapolate
between domains but do you think that
those analogies are
your creation
or are you just discovering them
so first of all i don't say that
anything of this is my creation like
that's been that's been known for a long
time
i mean i mean your mental framework to
understand the world is it alex's
framework or do you think you've just
discovered some
platonic framework
no no it's it's definitely it's my
friend it's a human framework of looking
at problems there's a reason that there
are some problems in
like
in in the human spec in space which are
unsolved for like hundreds and hundreds
of years and there are other problems
which are like which are probably
equally difficult in like an objective
level whether that exists another pro
question but which are solved like
pretty quickly
i believe the reason is that humans have
an inherent like bias towards certain
kinds of problems
it's very hard for humans to suss out
what actually these biases are
and this is also something where like
where machine learning now has a problem
so for example um in like causality is
something that a probability theory
nobody really took a look at because but
obviously if the barometer goes up it
doesn't mean that the barometer caused
the world to heat up but the heat caused
the barometer to grow
but
if
for for machine it's not necessarily
that simple it could be
that actually barometer gonna affect the
world
and they believe that many of those like
counterintuitive things are things that
these are very very tough nuts to crack
like in
in like causality and finance in also
mathematics that things that just defy
like these common mental frameworks and
these are just these impossible puzzles
there's a lot of discussion at the
moment about causal representation
learning from observational data um not
just learning the causal factors but
learning the causal structure and this
seems to me to be very related to all
the discussion we've just had so it's
related to finding these abstract
cognitive categories
if you think about it the causal
structure is a type of cognitive
category and i also think it's related
to the concept of geometric deep
learning and also to extrapolation
because causality structure is all about
being able to extrapolate into different
situations and being kind of invariant
to all of the things that it that it
shouldn't be connected to and then the
situation gets more complicated because
in the real world unfortunately
everything is correlated and as we said
earlier unfortunately in neural networks
everything is linked even the blue pixel
is probably linked to whether or not we
take a certain action
so do you think just coming back to
causality in geometric deep learning
we've hand-baked these inductive price
and they work very well
do you think we could do the same thing
for causal structure or do you think
it's actually empirically learnable from
observational data
if you just have observational data then
you can actually show that there are
circumstances in which you actually
can't learn that that's one of the like
core ideas of like for example the dude
calculus of pearl
that
that there's some things you have to
like interact with the world to kind of
force uh force a decision about certain
connections
but i think from like if you have that
if you have this interaction then
probably yes
on the other hand there's always the
question so you can probably learn that
i mean
on the other hand there's always a
question of does it make sense to
actually do this so
if it's even if it's technically
possible is it practically useful
and practically i would say
be careful with saying that because
fires cause observations they may
involve doing things that are just not
practically possible
and you just have to like opine from
from above and say these connections
have to exist like that for example
there are some things in like in the
medical sphere for example dieting is
one of those examples
of examples where you want to ask a
question of what happens if somebody
just eats fish for all their lives
and in practice you can't actually do
that like you can't take a meaningful
population say okay the entirety of
sweden now just eats fish
so you just have to
have some connections which just say
bake that into the architecture
and i believe that and the idea of
having priors so it's kind of the same
idea having an easy framework where you
can just say i know this about the real
world i know the temperature affects the
barometer and not up no the other way
around being able to have that knowledge
and very quickly plugging that into some
learning system is going to be like the
actual next big thing
we have all the knowledge we already
have like books and books and books you
can just dump into a network and use
that as a bias to accelerate everything
else
i think it is important to point out
that even the concept of
defining causality um
isn't necessarily um isn't necessarily
straightforward i mean there are quite a
bit of uh philosophical you know
discussions around it very you know
varying definitions of it counterfactual
versus structural you know et cetera so
i mean
and it even crops up um at least let's
say choices of of convention and how you
and how you define causality
uh can kind of have far-reaching effects
on on what you decide
you know the meaning of an experiment is
for example i mean you know with with
even like saying quantum mechanics where
people are always talking about uh
bell inequalities you know well that has
the assumption of statistical
independence and depending on which kind
of definition of causality you choose it
either is or is not the worst
you know um possible catastrophe if you
relax that
that um you know requirement of
statistical independence right so it is
just worth pointing out for those that
want to go and look into this field um
there's a lot of variety in how to
define this but i want to ask you alex
of those various operational definitions
of causality
which one do you find is the most
practically useful for
let's say work in the in the machine
learning field
it's probably pearls do calculus just
because it has a very very probabilistic
view with
like very minimal axioms you would
actually have to introduce like you have
this do which basically forces a certain
connection and then basically you
you run through and basically this
characteristic basically does this
combinations it's also very easy to
write it down as a graph in a lot of
sense correlation is good enough you
know for for a lot a lot of the work
that that a scientist is going to do or
a machine learning you know practitioner
um if they can find very strong
correlations then it just becomes a
matter of which of these correlated
variables can i control or not control
and then it almost becomes obvious a lot
of people criticize machine learning
practitioners because of the lack of
causality in our models but and this is
another thing i see at work actually
which is the lack of counter factual
reasoning um is a huge problem with many
of the metrics that are used uh i mean
zillow for example they recently went
out i think they went bust and that was
because they thought their machine
learning models were working very well
but they clearly didn't have a baseline
or a counterfactual the entire market
was just going up and then when it
stopped going up their models broke i
just wanted to finish by talking about
discrete program synthesis so i'm really
excited about this and as i said i'm
building a code of view platform at the
moment and i think i've got an exciting
use case for it which is when a pull
request comes in
we need to inductively categorize a
situation so wouldn't it be cool if we
could select some text we've
automatically passed a bunch of
representational
information it might be an abstract
syntax tree it might be a reference
graph or something like that and you
know we could just select some text and
do some back testing and do some
inductive uh program synthesis what
could possibly go wrong and there are
some really cool models out there like
dreamcoder for example which you know
supposedly reduced this factorial search
space in respect of the program length
um to
a linear search problem because you now
have a neural network which will predict
how good some of these sub modules are
in respect of a given task so does this
sound a little bit like um snake oil to
you or do you think there's something
interesting
people are very quick to declare a
victory in the space
like quantum computing
there are many many different things you
could do in programming or
um like
in general
in in specifically in this discrete
space where as soon as you have
basically like general lambda calculus
you can
do that then you could basically bop
circle could do anything you want
and that leads to
big problems down the line if a model
works very well in what you've tested it
it doesn't mean it it goes anywhere
else and
uh
you see that in for example theorem
proven there is this is idea so
at the university i'm at fau there is
michael kohlhausen and he basically like
very like very like 20 years ago he said
that
um
the current way of kind of building like
these reasoning systems is kind of it's
suboptimal because what's happening is
people have a great idea like
researchers have a great idea they built
that modern actually it works very well
on like some unknown problem
and but and then they build up the
system and and at some point like the
next system is going to come up and
supersede that
what people then forget is that by
introducing that new that new project it
doesn't mean that everything old still
works
so
for example there's in type 3 there's
this hyped topic called homotopic type
theory where basically you model
everything as a topology and this works
incredibly well for anything like
differential geometry like
writing down these kinds of things
but there are some things which just get
very very hard because for example you
don't have unique identity anymore so
what he came up with is the idea of well
let's just have a meta system where
basically we write down everything else
so basically we have an endpoint for
this an endpoint for that and the actual
like the actual system just does
translation work between these different
uh calculi
but uh they've been working on that for
like 20 years now
they are nowhere close to being done
there's always a problem that if you
want to do that you have to go to like
levels of generality i can't even
comprehend
this is kind of this is kind of the
problem because this space really what
would be interesting for machine
learning
but
even even this space basically just says
well we have that like these nice rule
systems that work very well for specific
systems but we still need one for each
each of them and we need an entirely
different level to kind of translate
between those and again
and basically this meta level always
changes because there's some new idea
and suddenly like some old assumption
doesn't work anymore because it's always
like this this moving goal post
and this is why i'm very careful like
like there was this open eye
thing for example with where they showed
like these mouthful ompi pro uh pro uh
programs
and for example they did that in lean
and i'm pretty sure if you took the
exact same system and you trained it on
like something like [ __ ] it wouldn't
work as well anymore because lean is
very very good at handling kind of these
numeric like these analysis problems and
[ __ ] doesn't do that as well it does
like the type theoretically like like
where you have like completely new type
theoretical building blocks that works
way better but suddenly you lose all
these biases you introduce that makes it
that make the like analysis part very
easy because suddenly you have things
that just never happen and i just now
are possible to have them there you have
to basically guard against them
you just get that explosion of options
so what's the what's the moral of the
story for tim in building his uh
his his business model should i just
give up finding the right
give up now that's it sounds like maybe
it's like you need to find
just be careful about which program
synthesis paradigm you choose maybe
that that captures the
um you know the important attributes
that you're trying to
you're trying to with with the program
recommendations maybe i don't know i
mean is that the lesson alex
you have to be careful with the battles
you choose to fight
like there are some things
you can do so for example a very popular
thing is uh making sure that this
program doesn't have any memory leaks or
doesn't have any race conditions and
that's very much doable
they're also but
they're also entire frameworks like
separation logic which are very well
doing specific things
but they also have some downside for
example separation logic basically
forces you to if you have some novel
like predicate you want to check you
have to define that predicate and
suddenly you have that additional layer
of you have the programmer which then
defines what's supposed to happen and
it's sometimes harder than actually
writing a program yourself and
so
but there's some parts of that which you
can use which you can deploy there's for
example facebook tool called infer
which for example does
uh like
memory safety and i think race
conditions they also do and some other
some other things and that's a battle
that that can you you can fight and that
you can actually win it's a sol it's a
solvable problem but if you say i want
to have like arbitrary things happen or
like the closer you go to arbitrary the
harder it becomes and i believe that
ultimately it's going to be like an
asymptotic problem where you're never
going to get of course like provable
you're never going to get to perfect
program induction
but you can get very very close but it's
going to be incredibly more expensive
yeah i have a similar intuition to you i
mean i think the gold standard and i'm
familiar with um infer by the way we
used that already i think the gold
standard would be some kind of program
recompilation and understanding and we
would actually know what they were
trying to do
and i think on on the the low hanging
fruit side of things you can think of it
as a glorified regular expression where
there's some kind of pattern matching
using some additional topological and
structural information
about the code this has been absolutely
amazing thank you so much for joining us
today it's been a wonderful conversation
yeah thank you alex thank you guys too
been great talking to you awesome yeah
always always a pleasure
if you enjoyed the show today don't
forget to like and subscribe and rate us
on apple podcasts see you next time